Học xin mới vùng đất, tìm xích vời sợ chận lúc hết trong đêm.
Học 2, 2 giờ tôi nghĩa vào mời tàn chính, sợ chận mời lửa cảo dải như dơ.
Được nước từ trên kè sối bắt ngờ đồ dũng, lần gặp trường phổ thông tin tộc bán chú tiểu học lực mình,
kể tương dương.
Lúc này, nhiều só viên vẫn đang chực ở trong trường, đã cùng nhau chẳng lên dự tán cất đồ dũng, tiếp bị học tập.
Thuy nhiên, sơ nước nập sơ để cả một mết, nên hầu hết các phòng học sẽ ngã ăn đều bị lập sâu.
Mài sợ viên còn có gần bài chả mọc sĩnh bán chú đang nhìn tạng giả nhạc cái tức sát.
Trong sạng này mật một tháng mời, sợ khi nước sốt đã đề lại lập bún đất sài,
hầu hết đồ dũng học tập sách bởi hư ông năng.
Nha chương phải cho học sinh nghỉ học lịch tập chung dọn dẹp,
các só viên học sinh lợi bún vào lất học lịch tìm lại sách bởi.
H hiện, các tự tự tử dựa bộ đổi, công nàn vàng vầy zân để phương,
công dọc bún đất để học sinh sướng quay trở lại học tập.